kidding ourselves that's what we are I'm
talking about our relationship with
alcohol but as a society and often it's
individuals alcohol-related deaths have
reached their highest level in a decade
and that's before you include people hit
by cars when they're drunk people who've
fallen choked on their own vomit killed
in drunken fights etc etc many of us
forgets that alcohol is a poison often a
nice tasting one but a poison on the
less it's become a default way of
celebrating socializing on winding and
let's face it numbing our sadness but
this poison which is also a depressant
by the way slips into our daily lives
far too easily it is the only drug that
you have to justify not taking
recognizing that you have a problem
often takes pints of self-awareness and
admitting it takes more than a shot
glass of honesty but it's time that we
do get honest and it's time that the
stigma around problem drinking is
removed and time we explore just why our
entire society seems so geared towards
alcohol because trust me if we don't
have these conversations
it will shortly be last orders for more
of us than I care to imagine so as you
were introducing Michelle couldn't help
but notice two things one is that your
puns themselves were references to
alcohol pint glasses shots
that's how embedded it is in our culture
I imagine it was the second thing I
couldn't help but notice was Nick's
facial reactions those they truly work
was offended for somebody that complains
about being offended
I've got to say I think you're right and
I've come at this as somebody
experiencing both ends of the alcohol
soaked culture that we live in I didn't
drink a drop of alcohol until I was
about 30 years old then I got divorced
and you know he made up resist his
history so I was actually completely
teetotal and it wasn't for religious
reasons even from the age of 14 15 16 I
just never got into it and then it
became religious reasons and then
religion kind of meant less to me and
then I sort of got divorces they started
drinking
and then I married my American wife who
coming from outside the country was
quite shocked actually at how much she
thinks we we drink to have a drink in
America at any work-related conference
is is is it's not really done and
actually to have a drink in the daytime
over lunch is not really done that's all
and yet in this country the first thing
that happens whether it's a lot a pint a
little cheeky pint at lunch or people
finish work for five and a head straight
to the pub she was quite surprised that
how our culture actually revolves around
alcohol and now I'm pretty much fully
booked what parts of that so I've got to
agree with you actually having heard
that external perspective as well I
think perhaps we we do have a bit of a
problem it's not healthy for us and this
is how many people die let's have a look
at this in 2017 there were seven
thousand six hundred and ninety seven
alcohol specific deaths in the UK and
that's just the deaths that are for
medical reasons not for the accidents
that occurs from alcohol not from what's
the population of this countries it's 67
million or something like that now seven
thousand six hundred is a horrible
figure but num-num in our sadness people
loads of people watching this will
happily go to see their families or
their friends I have a couple of glasses
of champagne or Christmas Day a glass of
red wine notify numbing this because you
can undermine the fact that actually
there's a significant problem with
rising mental health in this country and
alcohol is a depressant and actually
there is a stat that 58 percent of
people say that we admit that they drink
and I would say that that is much lower
than it would be I am categorically a
hundred percent sure that many people
are going there down they depress
they're actually you just had a tough
day you wanna go see
because I drink I do like a drink I love
good wine I'm into rum if I was earlier
talking about Rahm Tony's cuz I'm really
cold today which is probably not
appropriate given the fact that we make
alcohol too much but I often go through
long periods where I don't drink and
what I've really noticed so I really
agree what's a long period sorry six
months don't drink
is that when I go to an event or to
borrow dinner and I say I'm not drinking
sometimes people think the sign of a
kind of social dependency that people
feel that if you're not drinking it
slightly ruins the whole atmosphere or
it makes them feel bad they shouldn't
and I think that speaks for the fact
that there is G there is an unhealthy
culture there's nothing wrong with
having a drink it's great if you can do
it and it may I don't you do it for the
right reasons
go ahead but I think we should talk
about the fact that people sometimes do
it for the wrong reasons but also I want
to say hey I just wanna say it's not
everyone in society it's not everyone in
society who has this problem because
just quickly our young people are very
sensible just look at this from 2005 18
percent of 16 24 year olds did not drink
alcohol but by 2015 that had nearly
doubled to a third nearly 29% of 1624
now don't drink so it's not yet everyone
though those two figures do correlate
also with they're dropping belief in
democracy few drinks too much Greg do I
drink too much sometimes I don't get
drunk but I sometimes do too much I take
a couple of months a year off and not
drink a double I won't ask you Michele
you've stopped drinking at me I have
you've stopped for how many days I think
I'm a tease
it's a bit like finding religion aren't
you this is this is you now saying I've
found it and I will do I recognize how
do you numb your sadness now but notice
what I'm saying you really shouldn't be
flipping about it's cuz I was
self-medicating with alcohol cuz I was
down I was and I am I didn't see it my
intro did not say everyone in the land
numbs their sadness because that would
make me a bit of an idiot I didn't say
that they didn't suggest that nor do I
think that is the case but I am Telling
You young man came home numb their
sadness they medicate their depression
using alcohol and all they are doing is
making it Wow I think Nick and they
protest too much
Nick I can't answer Greg's point is this
that like the person who gives up
smoking and then know I love alcohol my
problem was I loved it slightly too much
so I've had to step back and I'm telling
you how I cannot even in your rising
this week but before we go there's just
time it can be an overwhelming
experience meeting a celebrity you know
as my fellow panelists testify to
everyone walk into the green room you
want to make a good impression and is
sure you make the most of the moment so
spare a thought for nine-year-old Nathan
who had this reaction when greeted by
the Queen and just a warning there's
some flash photography and that they're
going to present the ceremony for us
today
I wish I could do that sometimes and
white beatings but I don't wanna be that
I just when I was at the BBC we
introduced this odd that you could pull
out your pocket and it said cut the crap
so even those meetings you put I can't
stand this any longer and then you go to
the bridge yes but you wouldn't want to
that's it for this week make sure you
tune in for a very special Christmas
edition of the pledge next week thanks
for watching
[Music]